bonjour à tous heureuse de vous
retrouver cette semaine avec guillaume
pelletier pour ce point de presse
hebdomadaire
ce point de presse que nous allons
commencer bien sûr en rendant un hommage
aux victimes des attentats qui ont eu
lieu hier en turquie et en côte d'ivoire
vous le savez le président de notre
mouvement s'est entretenu hier avec le
président de côte d'ivoire où il a
rappelé évidemment être la plus grande
fermeté la condamnation de l'attentât
qui s'était passé à grand bassam et qui
a fait de nombreuses victimes
il a exprimé au peuple ivoirien et à ses
dirigeants sa totale solidarité et lors
de son entretien téléphonique avec le
président ouattara
il lui a témoigné bien sûr le soutien du
mouvement des républicains dans cette
terrible épreuve
il a rappelé combien cette attaque
odieuse de cette barbarie terroriste
était bien sûr pour nous tous un ennemi
commun et qu elle déclaré n'ont pas la
guerre à leur pays mais un pays tout
entier et à une civilisation tout
entière face à elle le président sarkozy
a rappelé qu' aucune faiblesse a été
permise et que nous devions continuer à
mener la guerre que les djihadistes nous
ont déclaré
c'est ensemble et unis que nous devons
la combattre car c'est ensemble et unis
que nous pouvons la vaincre a rappelé le
président sarkozy lors de cet entretien
avec le président ouattara il a été
convenu que la visite qui était prévu
initialement
en côte d'ivoire cette semaine serait
maintenu dans ces tristes circonstances
vous comprendrez bien que cette visite
prendra une dimension symbolique encore
plus forte
la france est un ami de la côte d'ivoire
est notre place bien sûr plus que jamais
et aux côtés de nos amis ivoiriens dans
cette terrible épreuve
c'est le message que portera le
président sarkozy lors de son
déplacement jeudi et vendredi prochains
nous allons parler avec guillaume de
plusieurs sujets bien sûr par sur la
politique intérieure et la politique
internationale
dans l'actualité de ce week-end je
voudrais bien sûr peut-être faire un
commentaire si vous le permettez sur les
élections partielles qui se sont
déroulées les trois élections partielles
dont vous avez pu constater comme nous
que les républicains se voit conforté
dans la dans le fait qu'ils sont la
première force politique de notre pays
c'est le premier constat puisque nous
sommes en capacité dans les trois
circonscriptions de gagner au second
tour la semaine prochaine autre ça c'est
l'effondrement du parti socialiste avec
un nouveau palier qui est atteint
puisque suivant les circonscriptions il
y à presque 20 points de différence avec
2012 donc je rappelle que dans la 10e
circonscription donc du nord de
tourcoing la 2e circonscription des
yvelines de versailles la 2e
circonscription de l'aisne
vincent ledoux pascal thévenot et julien
dive sont donc largement arrivé en tête
avec 47 8% dans l'aisne 46,1 dans les
yvelines et 36,3 dans l'aisne
dans ces trois partielles le parti
socialiste a donc obtenu des résultats à
bissau puisqu'ils n'ont obtenu
respectivement que 11 5% 13% et 15,7
pour cent
je rappelle également que lors des
dernières élections législatives en 2012
le parti socialiste avait été en
capacité de se maintenir au second tour
ce qui n'est donc pas le cas dans deux
circonscriptions
par ailleurs je voudrais maintenant
peut-être passer la parole d'abord à
guillaume et je reviendrai après sur la
situation sociale libye merci brigitte
seth est parfaite
quelques bonjour à tous quelques mots
évidemment sur l'un des sujets
d'actualité sur le plan national
aujourd'hui en particulier en ce début
d'après midi
tout à l'heure au moment où va
poursuivre ses rencontres avec ceux
qu'on appelle les partenaires sociaux et
les organisations non représentative de
jeunes par exemple pour vous faire une
analyse avec un peu de hauteur par
rapport à skis
manière profonde dans notre pays on a eu
tout au long de l'année 2015 à travers
la loi dite macron un grand nombre
d'annoncés est au fond le l'exercice du
ministère de la parole puisque à la fin
de la fin la loi macron qui devait
totalement libérer des énergies redonner
de l'oxygène aux entrepreneurs de notre
pays à l'économie nationale a abouti
cette fois uniquement à quelques
réformes liées aux autocars ou à
quelques autorisation sous conditions
pour travailler le dimanche
c'est ce que nous avons appelé nous une
loi qui donc voilà la montagne avait
accouché d'une souris
et là force est de constater qu'avec la
loi et le comme riz dit-elle comrie le
la tendance la dynamique ou plutôt
l'absence de dynamique sont encore pire
que ce qu'on avait connu avec la loi
dite macron la montagne ne semble pas
accouché d'une souris mais plutôt d'une
fourmi je m'explique dans les détails on
attendait à travers cette loi de la
flexibilité à l'envi à foison si l'on en
croit les déclarations du président de
la république du premier ministre et de
l'ensemble du gouvernement
on s'attendait par exemple enfin à une
certaine liberté sur la question des
indemnités prud'homale liberté pour les
entreprises un peu plus d'oxygène un peu
moins de réglementation et une clarté
pour les entrepreneurs
il n'en est rien on attendait sur la
grand nombre de sujets je pense oh la la
question des licenciements économiques
par exemple
là encore des atouts supplémentaires
dans le domaine de la souplesse et du
pragmatisme et on voit que tout au long
du week end les différentes négociations
qui ont lieu entre l'elysée matignon
les parlementaires frondeurs et
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
plutôt que de la flexibilité
supplémentaire cette loi semble
aujourd'hui hélas annoncé des
contraintes supplémentaires
on le voit dans un certain nombre de
domaines j'envoie un en particulier ce
matin
c'est la fameuse question de la banque
du temps pour tous c'est à dire qu'en
plus du conte pénibilité qui abîment
déjà en profondeur la liberté
d'entreprendre la souplesse que
réclament les entrepreneurs et en
particulier les patrons de pme de tpe
les artisans les commerçants dans notre
pays aujourd'hui on voit que cette loi
elle comme riz sous la pression d'une
petite partie de la rue semble
s'acheminer vers davantage de
contraintes et nous le regrettons
et c'est vrai qu'en cette période et je
le disais au siège des républicains sans
perdre l'esprit laïque qui est le nôtre
le chemin choisi par monsieur hollande
et valls et par madame l conneries
semble s'apparenter de plus en plus un
chemin de croix puisque de station en
station
nous avons eu le ministère de la parole
puis le ministère de la lâcheté plus le
ministère du reniement
puis le ministère du renoncement sur
toutes les grandes thématiques annoncé
sur tous les grands enjeux fondamentaux
qu'attendent nos compatriotes
qu'attendent nos concitoyens
qu'attendent les quelques 2 millions
d'entrepreneurs dans notre pays qui
souhaitent au quotidien créer de la
richesse de la croissance et de l'emploi
sur toutes ces thématiques
c'est hélas le chemin de croix le
ministère de la parole de la lâcheté du
reniement du renoncement et du blabla
qui l'emportent et on s'éloigne chaque
jour davantage du pragmatisme qui
devrait présider aux destinées de la
france avec françois hollande
c'est toujours le dogmatisme qui
l'emportent sur le pragmatisme c'est
toujours ce sont toujours les anciens
qui l'emportent sur les modernes et
c'est toujours au fond son propre parti
le parti socialiste au combien divisé
qui l'emportent sur l'intérêt général de
notre pays et nous le regrettons et nous
savons hélas que à travers cette loi
elle conneries il y aussi d'autres
reculs et d'autres dangers qui pointe le
bout du nez je sais que tu vas en dire
quelques mots sur la fonction publique
oui merci guillaume tu viens de rappeler
aussi un maître mot dans ce quinquennat
c'est l'amateurisme l'amateurisme de
françois hollande et de manuel valls qui
va dire
grandissant et où aujourd'hui nous nous
trouvons face au mur où ils se trouvent
face au mur leur raisonnement d'ailleurs
dont on voit qu'il va nous conduire un
fiasco total d'ici la fin de ce
quinquennat fait que nous avons à la
tête de l'exécutif
un président de la république et un
premier ministre qui pour la troisième
fois consécutive apparemment vont écrire
ou honte écrit sur un bout de table au
débotté un projet de loi rappelez-vous
cela avait déjà été le cas pour la
réforme territoriale fait de manière
pour le moins incongrue un découpage qui
dont lequel d'ailleurs nous ne remettons
toujours pas même topo pour la déchéance
de la nationalité écrit à la va-vite
présenter n'importe comment
et aujourd'hui nous assistons à nouveau
avec ce projet de loi elle conneries à
une réécriture fait en catimini hier
dans les murs les quatre murs de
l'elysée pour être présenté avec
quelques fuites
en effet aujourd'hui sur ce que son
devenir mais il ya d'autres sujets qui
vont faire la une de la de la semaine au
niveau social c est cela vous aura
sûrement pas échappé
les prises de position là aussi pour le
moins à de manière amateur de la
ministre madame gérardin ministre de la
fonction publique qui a déclaré à deux
jours d'intervalle sont tout et son
contraire si je puis dire puisque vous
le savez il y avait une négociation qui
était envisagé sur le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
cela avait été retardé dans les
négociations salariales car il espérait
qu'en le mettant à la fin du quinquennat
la situation économique serait tel que
les fonctionnaires en sortiraient
gagnants mais nous sommes évidemment à
l'opposé de la situation à l'époque
espéré par les partenaires sociaux
les négociations qui vont s'entamer
cette semaine sur l'augmentation part de
ce point d' indices vont être
concomitante à l'agenda de la discussion
de la loi elle conneries ça n'est pas de
chance mais surtout malheureusement on
voit bien que cela va influencer le
gouvernement puisque au départ
madame gérardin nous annoncer que
l'augmentation de lundi ce n'était pas à
l'ordre du jour elle disait le 23
février nous devons composer avec la
réalité budgétaire et nous avons à
regarder les choses d'un point de vue
macroéconomique le dégel du point
d'indicé étant lié aux indicateurs
économiques mais le lendemain
sûrement avec un petit rappel à l'ordre
est en vue de la nécessité j'imagine de
calmer les syndicats cette même ministre
parlait de la nécessité d'un geste
salariale et qui serait un signal
important alors nous voyons bien à
nouveau ce que vient d'ailleurs souligné
guillaume c'est à dire aussi un
gouvernement qui gouverne à la petite
semaine et qui en fait gouverne par le
poids des syndicats
est ce que à un moment aussi en france
on peut gouverner dans la réforme
où va-t-il falloir attendre en effet je
le crains en effet ça sera la réforme
pour 2017 car la loi elle comrie qui
s'installent là dans la discussion va
donc jouer on l'a vu et aujourd'hui nous
a été annoncé par la cgt des préavis de
grève du 17 au 31 mars
ça c'est pour monsieur fernandez quand
par ailleurs monsieur bergé a l'air de
se transformer en ministre bis du
travail en ce qui nous concerne et vous
le savez nous avions eu cette semaine
une journée de travail sur la réforme de
l'état et sur la fonction publique
et je vous rappelle que si
l'augmentation de l'indicé en tant que
telle n'est pas tabou en aucun cas se
laisse cela ne fait une politique de la
fonction publique
nous avons eu une matinée où nous avons
rappelé au niveau des républicains notre
souhait en effet d'une nouvelle fonction
publique c'est-à-dire des fonctionnaires
qui soit mieux considérée une fonction
plus performante et plus efficace mais
qui soit remaniée dans une grande équité
entre le public et le privé
le statut de fonctionnaire pour nous
doit être remanié dans son ensemble il
doit tenir compte des évolutions du
monde du travail avec évidemment une
logique du soit fondée sur le mérite qui
évidemment n'est pas un mot tabou se
mérite et évidemment qui doit être mis
en valeur par rapport à une augmentation
la ryal et nous devons aussi pouvoir
offrir aux fonctionnaires la possibilité
d'avoir recours au contrat donc nous
pour nous il n'ya pas donc de sujet
tabou mais il est important peut-être
aussi de vous rappeler que pour nous le
système de rémunération des
fonctionnaires doit donc être d'abord
tournée vers le mérite et la performance
dois je vous rappeler que sur 5,7
millions de fonctionnaires si nous
augmentions d'un point 'l'indice et bien
nous atteignons 1,8 milliard d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires ou l'état à
l'heure actuelle il retrouvé 1 8
milliard d'euros
est ce la priorité la rue la réponse est
non la réponse est d'avoir une réflexion
globale et ça n'est pas ce vers quoi
nous allons car une fois de plus comme
le disait un instant bio nous sommes
dans une dans une manière d'appréhender
les dossiers qui ne sont pas ceux de
professionnels c'est l'amateurisme à
chaque coin de rue si je puis dire en
tout cas à chaque décision
gouvernementale c'est un pas en avant
deux pas en arrière
pardon là maintenant on va parler
peut-être donc de l'international le
lien entre l'articulation entre les
questions européennes et des questions
nationales toujours à travers pour
conclure sur le sujet la loi elle comme
risquées comme la grande actualité du
jour vous dire notre préoccupation et je
dis bien en lien avec cette loi qui je
vous le rappelle prévoit ou prévoyez on
ne sait plus une part de réforme un peu
plus audacieux sur la question centrale
particulièrement dans le monde rural
particulièrement en province des
travailleurs détachés et on voulait dans
un esprit constructif passer un petit
moment là dessus parce que vous savez
combien quand on lit les différents
rapports parlementaires sénatoriaux
européen vous avec un à l'heure où je
parle avec brigitte la commission
européenne est en train de réfléchir à
des nouveaux aménagements
car la question du travail détachées est
une bombe à retardement à l'échelle de
l'union européenne et exaspère chaque
jour davantage nos compatriotes français
mais aussi européens je vous rappelle
quelques chiffres
selon le gouvernement français ce sont
trente mille travailleurs détachés
légaux sur le territoire national en
2014-2015 auxquels peuvent s'ajouter de
80000 à 200 mille travailleurs détachés
illégaux selon les différentes sources
nationales et européennes il y à une
exaspération complète et totale de
l'ensemble des entrepreneurs de
l'ensemble des élus sur le territoire
national les reportages les analyses les
fraudes se comptent désormais par
milliers
et vous savez qu'à ce type le
gouvernement entendant la colère de nos
compatriotes avaient souhaité intégrer
dans la loi elle comme riz non pas une
mesure mais une mesurette
complémentaires pour lutter contre les
conséquences de cette concurrence
déloyale
nous nous demandons ce matin dans le
cadre de la loi elle commis au nom du
pragmatisme et pour apporter une réponse
concrète à la colère des entrepreneurs
et au nom de la justice sociale nous
demandons une remise à plat complète du
système des travailleurs détachés en
europe et en france ça n'est plus
possible
on sait très bien les mesures qu'il faut
prendre pour pouvoir y remédier cela
passe d'abord par un renforcement
considérable de la lutte contre la
fraude qui touche aussi bien les
entreprises que les particuliers
cela passe par une voix courageuses de
la commission européenne par exemple sur
un délai limite limitée dans le temps de
la possibilité d'effectuer du travail
était tachée cela passe évidemment on
l'espérait un peu à travers la loi elle
comrie il faudra probablement attendre
2017 par une une compensation général de
la question du coût du travail le
travail d'étagés je vous rappelle c'est
tout
tout le cadre légal du pays d'accueil
sauf et c'est là que le bât blesse
sauf la question des charges qui relève
du pays d'origine et donc cela crée des
distorsions de concurrence de la
concurrence déloyale un dumping fiscal
et social très lourd pour l'ensemble des
travailleurs de notre pays donc au nom
des travailleurs francs
c'est au nom des entrepreneurs français
nous demandons cette remise à plat
complète nous demandons non pas une
concurrence déloyale mais une
concurrence juste et cela peut
s'incarner à travers les quelques
mesures évoquées et l'une évidemment qui
sera fondamental c'est un processus
réclamée par nicolas sarkozy et eric
woerth par exemple c'est un système de
compensation claire et nette sur la
question des charges pour qu' il y ait
une égalité de traitement entre un
travailleur français est un travailleur
étranger
cela fait des années que nous le
dénonçons cette directive date vous le
savez de 1996 de décembre 96 le nom
français en 2005 au traité
constitutionnel a pris aussi ses racines
à travers rappelez vous la fameuse
question du plombier polonais a pris ses
racines à travers cette exaspération
d'une europe qui ne se soumet trop
souvent aux marchés financiers et à une
vision ultra libérale du monde l'europe
de demain se doit d'être une europe
forte juste équitable et qui sache
défendre les travailleurs les ouvriers
les agriculteurs de france et de tous
les autres pays de l'union européenne et
cette loi elle comme riz est une
opportunité historique
si l'on est courageux pour intégrer dans
cette réforme législative des
dispositifs de lutte contre la fraude de
travail détachées et de rétablissement
de la justice sociale et d'une
concurrence juste toujours sur la
question européenne est en nous
éloignant un peu évidemment de la loi
elle conneries nous voudrions aussi avec
brigitte et l'ensemble du mouvement vous
dire notre inquiétude sur la question du
rapport et du lien entre la turquie et
l'union européenne
d'un côté et de la place de la france au
sein de l'union européenne
nicolas sarkozy savait lorsqu'il était
prise au la république incarner un
leadership fort et puissant et la france
était une puissance entendus et écoutés
aujourd'hui tout le monde le reconnaît
entre la france et l'allemagne
le divorce semble consommé et l'absence
d'autorité de cap d'incarnation de
vision de françois hollande interdisent
hélas à la france de défendre c'est sa
position sur un certain nombre de sujets
et entre autres sur la question majeure
du rapport entre la turquie et l'union
européenne
nous réclamons nous les républiques
comme préalable absolue à toutes les
discussions en cours entre la turquie et
l'union européenne
le refus clair net assumer le refus
clair net assumé de l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne
nous l'avons dit tout au long des
dernières années nicolas sarkozy l'a
incarné lorsqu'il était le président de
la république dans notre pays et nous
tenons à cette cohérence car tout autre
chemin tout autres évocations vous le
savez bien est un mensonge adressé au
peuple européen et au peuple turc
nous ne voulons pas de l'adhésion de la
turquie dans l'union européenne et nous
faisons de ce refus clair un préalable à
toute nouvelle discussion bien sûr que
le rôle de la turquie est essentiel dans
la gestion de la crise des migrants et
des réfugiés
bien sûr que nous vous devons discuter
avec la turquie
bien sûr que nous devons continuer à
travailler de concert sur ces sujets
essentiels mais une coopération
intelligente est valable et durable ne
se construit jamais sur un mensonge et
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne n'ait voulu par quasiment
aucun dirigeant européen par aucun
peuple européen et nous devons avoir un
discours et des actes de clarté sur
cette question centrale d'autant plus
avant de laisser la parole à brigitte
que nous vous alertons sur un nouveau
problème qui va être posée à l'union
européenne dans les prochains mois c'est
qu'avant la fin de l'année 2016 au nom
de la réunification de chypre la langue
turque
enfin devenir probablement la langue
officielle là l'une des langues
officielles de l'union européenne
donc imaginer le désarroi des peuples
européens
on avait été clair depuis quelques
années les peuples se sont exprimés les
dirigeants se sont exprimés pour refuser
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne à travers la crise des
migrants et des réfugiés à travers la
position de l'allemagne
une ambiguïté nouvelle dénoncée par tous
les ténors de notre formation politique
aujourd'hui avec une vraie cohérence sur
la question de nicolas sarkozy à alain
juppé tout le monde est clair sur la
question de l'entrée de la turquie dans
l'union européenne
ces ambiguïtés se multiplient et on va
avoir dans quelques mois un nouveau
sujet sur la table
est ce que la langue turque peut devenir
l'une des langues officielles de l'union
européenne ces ambiguïtés sont
dangereuses et c'est dans une politique
de clarté une coopération avec la
turquie mais un refus de son entrée et
de son intégration que nous pourrons
construire l'europe de demain avec des
frontières sûres pour l'intérêt de
l'union européenne comme pour
l'extérieur de l'union européenne
j'étais un peu long à ce sujet rien à
ajouter
on va plutôt favorisé les questions avec
vous mais je voudrais complété par
rapport à la vie du mouvement d'habitude
évidemment je commence le point presse
par là mais je souhaitais que nous
commencions évidemment par l'hommage aux
victimes et lorsque je vous disais que
le président sarkozy se rendrait donc
jeudi et vendredi prochain dans le cadre
d'un déplacement qui était prévu de
longue date
à l'invitation du président ouattara il
se rendra donc pour évidemment rendre
hommage aux victimes et de son émotion
et sa solidarité sur les lieux mêmes où
au lieu la tuerie ont eu lieu la tuerie
donc ses déplacements ces jeudi et
vendredi
mardi nous aurons la commission
exécutive qui aura lieu à 18h comme tous
les 15 jours
mercredi soir le président nicolas
sarkozy assistera au dîner annuel du
conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer enfin concernant l'agenda de
notre mouvement je voudrais vous
annoncer deux matinées de travail les
deux prochaines auront lieu les 30 mars
et le 5 avril le 30 mars
johnny travail consacré à l'économie sur
les dépenses publiques et la fiscalité
et le 5 avril elle sera consacrée à
l'éducation
enfin autre nouvelle nous sommes vous le
savez quatre porte parole avec guillaume
pelletier guillaume larrivé valérie de
bord un cinquième va venir rejoindre
notre équipe qui sera particulièrement
chargé entre autres des questions aux
européennes il s'agit de philippe juvin
député européen qui sera donc présente
dès que les questions européennes seront
à l'ordre du jour enfin au delà de
l'agenda qui vous a été distribué vous
avez dû trouver sur votre table le
dernier magazine des républicains qui
nous évoque qui va dans le détail du
projet collectif pour les républicains
que nous avons adoptée lors de notre
dernier conseil national en février
dernier voilà je vous remercie et la
parole maintenant est à vous pour des
questions